hey what is up guys mkbhd here and today
we're going to be talking about the
potential successor to the already
legendary htc one now we don't actually
know what the name of that phone is
going to be it could be the htc 2 or the
htc one
v2 we don't actually know but we do know
that it's at least internally code named
the htc m8 so that is what we're going
to be calling it for this entire video
so the htc one was one of my favorite
phones of 2013
period hands down it had amazing specs
it had excellent speakers and it had a
build quality that set a new standard
for what high-end smartphones should
feel like of that unibody aluminum so
whatever the new name of this new htc
smartphone is it's going to have some
seriously big shoes to fill so the
rumored specs here are a little bit less
than concrete obviously nothing is
confirmed but i'll give you the spec
rundown and you can let me know what you
think first of all we are expected to
keep that legendary unibody aluminum
design and the front-facing speakers
without that i don't even know if we
could call the successor to the htc one
so yes this m8 is expected to have the
same beastly build quality now similar
to this build quality we're also
expected to keep these premium specs so
it's also expected to launch with uh
newest version of the snapdragon 800 not
the 805 and 2 gigabytes of ram and the
newest version of android android 4.4.2
with sense 6 on top of it which brings
us to the next point the physical design
of the phone is expected to switch from
htc's off-screen buttons to htc's
on-screen buttons so we've seen leaked
screenshots now of htc sense 6 on the m8
and it does have software on screen
buttons which would lead to a slight
change in design so the htc one had a
4.7 inch 1080p display and if you look
at the phone from like take a step back
it actually had really big bezels
because of the huge speakers on the top
and the bottom so having these on-screen
buttons now would require a little bit
more space so we're expected to see a
slightly larger display coming in at 5.0
inches five inch 1080p display is still
way over 400 ppi so it's going to look
extremely sharp and of course it'll have
the on-screen buttons now so slightly
less bezels so love it or hate it that's
probably going to be a thing those
buttons are going to be moving to
on-screen probably 90 chance of that
happening and then there is the camera
probably the biggest question mark ever
so we've seen these leaked shots of a
new htc flagship that looks like the htc
m8 that has two cameras two physical
camera aperture openings two different
sensors uh on the top and middle of the
phone these are expected to actually be
used by htc not for 3d nothing crazy
like that but to actually be used for
some htc software for refocusing a shot
after it's taken and some other pixel
depth things and i'll leave a link below
to a toshiba phone that actually already
does this so it has two five megapixel
sensors and uses toshiba software to
refocus a shot afterwards i'll leave a
link below the like button to check that
out and i guess we're expecting now the
new htc m8 to have this same feature
that seems pretty cool and they're also
apparently sticking with the ultra
pixels i did a video all on the
ultrapixel explained as you probably
already know the htc one had a four
ultra pixel or four megapixel camera
this is supposed to be improved and i'm
actually happy that they're improving
this because it had massive potential
obviously the low-light shots could be
better with something like optical image
stabilization so if they stick with this
ultra pixel thing and improve the
technology and make it better who knows
maybe it will be way better than the
typical cmos sensor with 15 or 18
megapixels so props htc for sticking
with that and i'm excited to see how
that performs so that's basically it
that is essentially what we know about
the new htc one it's not everything you
know it doesn't give you a full picture
but it should give you a pretty good
idea of what the phone is going to look
like and feel like in the hand
especially if you've held an htc one
before
i'm also expecting personally
performance to be excellent even though
it's not the newest 805 chip from
qualcomm uh the snapdragon 800 does
really really well with android 4.4
kitkat because of its lower system
requirements and taking better advantage
of lower specs so i'm expecting
performance to be great it's all going
to depend on htc sense 6.0 here and what
sort of software htc decides to throw
into that and we're also expecting this
phone to drop sometime in late march i
think the window that we originally
thought was q1 which is a pretty big
window now we're in february and it's
sort of narrowing down to late march
here and i'll keep you guys updated on
twitter if i find an event date or
something official like that now i'm
sure there will be way more leaks
between now and then i mean it's 2014
everything leaks and i'm sure there will
be way more before the phone actually
comes out but if you're not interested
in the htc one or the m8 at all i
actually also uploaded a video today on
the samsung galaxy s5 and what to expect
with that phone so if you're more into
the galaxy s line you can check that out
yes i did upload two videos in one day
today so check those both out i'll have
that link also below the like button so
there's just a whole bunch of links
below in the description to check out
again that has been it hope you enjoy it
thank you for watching and i'll talk to
you guys in the next one
peace
you